he throws latest terminal is three
months from its grand opening when fully
operational the 4.2 billion dollar
terminal will handle 25,000 passengers a
day but memories of the 2008 nightmare
terminal 5 launch our fresh in the
airport mind treatments appeal today was
appalling luggage was lost 600 flights
were delayed it was embarrassing and
cost twenty six million dollars in
expenses and damages was very poor day
from British Airways we've got 400
pollen k is the man responsible for
making sure that doesn't happen again
opening a new airport terminal is the
most challenging thing any Apple can
take on you can can the number of
successful airport openings on the
fingers of one hand one of the
advantages we have in opening terminal 2
is that we've got the experience of
terminal 5 the plan is to open terminal
2 in slow motion united airlines is the
only carrier that will fly in first then
a new carrier will join every three
weeks the opening comes as he throws
future is under review the UK's only hub
airport is fighting to expand Holland k
argues this investment strengthens their
case Angus Bennett Bloomberg